たくみ）これヤバくね？
はじめ）誰？
やばいやばいやばい
（ヒソヒソ話）
たくみ）ほぉ～　は）やばいやばいやばい
は）マジか
は）いやいやいや
ヤバい～
た）よし次
は）ヤバいねぇ
三人）あぁぁ～
三人）う～わ～　やっべぇぞコレ
は）おいすげーよ！
（ヒソヒソ話）
三人）あ～あ～あ～
三人）ぁぁああああやばいやばいやばい
ﾌﾞｩ~ｯ（膨らませる音）
は）おい！ヤバいヤバい！
は）マジこの本は読めない
は）この本は読めない
二人）それはやべぇ
ﾌﾞｩ~（ブーブークッションの音）
は）はっ！？お前ら…
係員）どうしました？
は）なんか...
は）いたずらしてきました
は）うわぁ！！
ｺﾞﾛｺﾞﾛｺﾞﾛ…（ビー玉が転がる音）
係）どうしました？
は）ビー玉が…
係）ビー玉？　は）はい
係）なんでビー玉を持っているんだい？
は）すいません…
わぁっ！
最後わざと落としてたような...
(ジェンガが倒れる音)
おい！！
何してるんだそりゃあ
いや...　すみません...
なぜジェンガをやるんだそこd
(いろんな音)
ああ、、、やっべ
どうしたんだそれは
なんだその　タンバリンかそれ
タンバリン
わあああっ！！　(またか)
(zzz)
(!?)
(ふつうは起きるだろw)
あっx7
いたっ!!　いだい!!
つ待って　いだい!!!!x20
wwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
おい!
なんで裸なんだっ
(音楽、大音量)
(音楽、持続。)
(音楽、持続。ただしフェードアウト中)
(音楽、大音量。これは絶対に気付いている
理由・・・びっくりしている＆自分からさしている)
おい!
(音楽、大音量。これは絶対に気付いている
理由・・・びっくりしている＆自分からさしている)
お前友達だろ?
(音楽、大音量。これは絶対に気付いている
理由・・・びっくりしている＆自分からさしている)
だれか教えてあげて
(音楽、大音量。これは絶対に気付いている
理由・・・びっくりしている＆自分からさしている)
おい!!
(音楽、大音量。これは絶対に気付いている
理由・・・びっくりしている＆自分からさしている)
ノリノリでやるなノリノリで!!
(音楽、大音量。これは絶対に気付いている
理由・・・びっくりしている＆自分からさしている)
(そして...)
(パン!)